energy bills are soaring because of
rising gas prices and ukraine's war with
russia
so should we pause or delay our climate
promises and take a hit on prices to
focus on punishing putin
russia is the world's second largest gas
producer and the third largest oil
exporter and any sanctions on its energy
industry would badly damage its own
economy
and have an impact on the rest of the
world
in europe very reliant
a whopping 40 of the continent's gas
supply and 30 of its oil comes from
russia and any disruption to that supply
line would have profound impacts
it's hard bloody hard but i am also
deeply convinced it is something we need
to do because now it's also intimately
linked to our security in the uk things
are a little easier we get about 45 of
our gas from the north sea
and only about 5 of our gas from russia
on top of that we import about a third
from norway considered a reliable
supplier
with war in ukraine continuing the u.s
has announced it will ban imports of
russian oil and gas it's the strongest
sanction yet and will send oil prices
surging ukraine will never be a victory
for putin so i said i would level with
the american people from the beginning
defending freedom is going to cost it's
going to cost us as well republicans and
democrats alike have been clear that we
must do this the uk has also said it
will ban imports of oil by the end of
2022. the uk is
is less exposed but
clearly we do have
diesel that comes from
russia we can't move overnight but we
can certainly do it and we can do it in
a way that doesn't disrupt supply
european countries have so far not
followed suit in terms of a full boycott
given their much heavier reliance on
russian energy but they have announced a
plan to reduce dependence on gas by
two-thirds within a year fit for 55 once
implemented will reduce the eu's total
gas consumption by 30 percent by 2030
that is
100 billion cubic meters of gas we will
no longer need
it's also not just world leaders who are
punishing putin after intense criticism
shell has announced it will stop buying
russian oil and gas following in the
footsteps of competitor bp
but the big question is how do we find a
suitable replacement for russia's oil
and gas
the un and the international energy
agency have been unequivocal nearly half
of humanity is living in the danger zone
now
many ecosystems are at the point of no
return
now and checked carbon pollution is
forcing the world's most vulnerable on a
frog march to destruction now there are
two different camps
some are arguing that we have to move
away from fossil fuels faster they say
successive governments have not invested
enough in renewable energy and nuclear
and had they done so europe would not be
so dependent on russia
the uk's independent advisory body the
climate change committee has made the
argument that even if the uk was to
increase its oil and gas production in
the north sea it would actually have a
marginal impact on lowering prices but
some argue that domestic oil and gas
production should be increased to make
sure that we're not reliant on russia at
least in the short term
that camp says that it will help with
security of supply and crucially the
perception of security of supply i think
the targets are extremely ambitious and
it's not clear to what extent they can
be reconciled with um the climate change
goals and you know you have this this
irony that germany in particular is
burning an awful lot of coal at the
moment so are they going to be burning
more dirty coal short term in order to
reduce the gas dependency very probably
i would say there is no doubt that we
need to shift to clean energy both for
the climate but now increasingly for
energy security
but as bills continue to skyrocket it's
still not clear how quickly the world
can make that happen
you